А що якби з вихлопної труби виходила лише вода…
Зрозуміло, що коли їдеш один, ти і є тим, хто спричиняє викиди C02.
Весь світ може цьому навчитися.
Наше виробництво водню у Босбюллі - це насправді бізнес-план, який можна застосувати будь-де у світі.
Селяни пишаються своїм досягненням.
Насправді чудово, що ми можемо виробляти та використовувати це.
Село Босбюлль розташоване на півночі Німеччини.
І це перший проєкт у ФРН, завдяки якому ця та ще кілька німецьких громад хочуть обійтися без викопного палива.
Вони повністю роблять ставку на водень. Але як це працює? І наскільки дорого для мешканців?
Уже кілька тижнів у штатному режимі працюють два водневі автобуси.
У рамках проєкту побудували кілька АЗС, де автомобілі також можуть заправлятися воднем.
А як водієві цей новий автобус?
Добре, що автобус їде безшумно. Ви чуєте лише, як працює електродвигун і кермовий механізм. Все решта - тиша.
Коли в автобусі є пасажири, можна навіть чути їхні розмови. Іноді це неприємно, але в якийсь момент
ти перестаєш слухати і вже звертаєш увагу на інші речі в автобусі та на трафік.
Але чи пасує автобус для повсякденного користування?
Наразі проблема в тому, що іноді важко заправитися.
Це означає, що автобус і система заправки не взаємодіють між собою.
Це проблема програмного забезпечення. Її можна вирішити за допомогою кількох оновлень.
А це - серце водневого проєкту Босбюлля.
Це наш електролізер - зараз відкрию.
Андре Штайнау втілив у життя цей проєкт. Його компанія керує електролізером.
Він коштував 8 мільйонів євро. Необхідний водень отримується з води у контейнері.
Для цього потрібно багато електроенергії.
Ми живемо у так званій зоні вузького місця мережі.
Це означає, що енергія вітру тут відключається, і в нас є надлишок електроенергії.
Тому і спало на думку: може, щось розпочати робити з цим струмом? Ми не хочемо його викидати.
І одна з ідей полягає в тому, щоб тимчасово зберігати цю електроенергію, коли є її надлишок,
а потім використовувати, якщо відновлювана енергія в той момент недоступна.
А потім знайти таке застосування, щоб ми могли не тільки повертати електроенергію назад у мережу,
але й в інші сектори, такі як транспорт і тепло.
І ось як це робиться: за допомогою енергії вітру водень виробляється з очищеної водопровідної води.
Потім його транспортують на місцеві водневі заправні станції.
Під час виробництва водню утворюється багато тепла.
Воно подається у місцеву мережу централізованого опалення, тому будинки у селищі Босбюлль опалюються СО2-нейтральним способом.
Макс Бьом має зиск з цього і поки проблем не виникало.
- Але чи не було б справедливо, якби при цьому знизилися витрати на опалення?
Адже в основному використовують те, що насправді є відходами.
Так, це було б добре, якби розрахунок був таким простим.
У цьому конкретному випадку насправді лише частина тепла отримується від виробництва водню,
і це за часом співпало з тим, що встановили електролізер і ми змогли побудувати свою теплову мережу.
Але тепломережа також працювала б і без електролізера і це не обов’язково робить її дешевшою.
Тепло нині - це початок загального проєкту і, звісно, також початок щодо застосування водню в транспорті.
Звісно, було б добре, якби в кожного перед дверима стояла одна чи дві водневі машини.
Щодо ціни, то нині ситуація не така, що кожен може собі це дозволити чи ми можемо собі це дозволити.
Але я можу собі добре уявити, що у цієї технології є майбутнє. Однозначно.
Водневий автомобіль коштує приблизно вдвічі дорожче ніж дизельна модель.
Тому в цьому регіоні їх лише 30.
Заправка також поки що дорога. За 500 кілометрів потрібно сплатити 50 євро, тоді як за дизель - 47, а за електромобіль - 25 євро.
Ми маємо звикнути до того, що економіка, орієнтована на захист клімату, дорожча за економіку, орієнтовану на викопне паливо.
Це означає захист клімату. І ми всі зацікавлені врятувати наш світ.
І нині ми перебуваємо на початку технології, яка існує вже давно.
Але це ще не масове використання - застосування цієї технології вже було, але завдяки масовому використанню вона ставатиме дешевшою.
У Босбюллі вважають, що вже за кілька років використання "зеленої" енергії не буде дорожчим, ніж використання звичайної енергії.
При цьому нова технологія вже придатна для повсякденного використання, і місцеві мешканці це довели.